talk about the good bad and the ugly of
writing meetings so how does a writer
personally contribute to the success or
failure of a pitch meeting or maybe it's
not really within their control but they
feel they've contributed to it you well
you do contribute to it and and it's
it's really grossly unfair to having
been on the other side of the desk
having been in studio executive it's
it's it's everyone has pitch nightmare
stories and they're true but it's really
unfair to development people in studio
executives to assume that everyone in
those meetings is there to make
basically make your life miserable and
say no to you it's not true and and why
and how you contribute to it as a writer
you come in with an idea that you've
actually thought through and that you
have some passion for and that and and
and that also you need to be willing to
listen it's a conversation and and the
control you have of the conversation is
you're the one coming in with the idea
you're the kind you're the one coming in
and saying hey I think this would be a
great movie this would be a great
television show whatever and you should
have thought it through and you should
have prepared well enough to when they
say well why do you think it's such a
great idea to be able to answer the
questions and you should know enough
about your story that that you can do it
justice in the room but then having sat
as an executive I've also been in those
meetings where you say to someone yeah I
get it but and they immediately what but
there is nobody this is the story you
have nothing to say to me and and a
defensive
this goes up and that's a huge mistake
you don't don't go to the meeting just
write the stupid script it's a
conversation it's a dialogue and don't
assume that you know more than the
person in the room who you're speaking
to have it as a conversation and be
strong and no one you need to dig in
your heels and know that that there are
they're there that if people are
changing your story in the room so much
that you don't even recognize it anymore
which could happen that you need to say
no and say thank you for the meeting and
leave but engage in the conversation
have a little bit of effing humility for
God's sakes you know you you've been
invited into the room that tells someone
a story you don't don't don't assume
that they that they don't have a thought
in their head and there are so many
stories and again a lot of them are true
and I could tell you nightmare stories
about pitches we could stay here all
night and I can tell you those stories
but it's but I could also tell you great
stories with great development people
who have given me enough rope to hang
myself then said that what if this
happened or that happened and they've
given me a better idea at a better take
it's a dialogue it's a conversation and
it's part of the it's part of the
business and I hate to call it a game
but I will for a moment it's part of the
game but if you just can't stand the
idea of going in and telling a story and
someone's going to try to change it or
have an idea write the script
don't be a pitch monkey be a
screenwriter so then how does a
screenwriter keep their side of the
street clean so whatever happens on the
other side of that desk whether the
person's kind with their suggestions or
not how do they keep their own integrity
and end end poised and all of that by
having integrity and and and knowing
that you you're going in with something
that you believe in and that you're
excited about
and so if they completely don't get it
or say stuff that you think has nothing
to do with what you just pitch with them
you know within yourself that the story
you went into tell is the story that you
want to tell and you really believe it
could be a movie and you can really be
excited about it
integrity integrity is an inside job and
if you if you're looking to have your
your integrity
brought to you by Hollywood oh my god no
no it's it's it's it's an inside job and
I if I go in to pitch a story I I don't
do it unless I believe in it and and and
I may be wrong I may be wildly wrong but
I I won't leave going well you know what
I thought I'd put that one over on him
but they didn't you know I you know they
but they didn't get it but oh well I
mean I'll go I told the best story I
could and then you let it go you just
let it go it's a good medium it's a bad
meeting but you did your best and that's
an inside job and it's a learned
experience too and you will come out of
meetings wondering who you are and and
what you're gonna be when you grow up
I still have meetings like that but but
most of the time I come away feeling
good yeah that was my next question had
a because oh it sounds like you just
have to go through it have a few where
you're like basically in the fetal
position when you go home and then it's
less so you're just on the couch and
then yeah just take a walk around the
block
yeah and I I don't end up in the fetal
position much anymore because I I
believe in what I do doesn't mean it
doesn't mean anyone else has to believe
in it but I believe but it sounds like
it was it's a learned thing and that
there's no there's no magic answer no no
there's no there's no magic answer and
again it's one of those things that I've
seen people get crushed in these
meetings crushed where they can't come
back
again and that's again that thing about
having an over developed sense of
perfection perfectionism to say it more
simply that will will be your worst
enemy you had a bad meeting I I was in a
there was there was this this time where
everything was supposed to be based on
Joseph Campbell remember those days when
everything you had to go in you know and
and and that was what you were supposed
to that was what you were you were
always if you were gonna pitch you were
you were gonna you you were gonna you
were gonna pitch something and you
Joseph Campbell was gonna end up in the
sentence and I was going in with a
producer who said now remember to get
the Joseph Campbell moments in there and
I was pitching I was about three minutes
into it and the guy across the desk said
oh Jesus Christ can we get over the
Joseph Campbell stuff can you just tell
me the story and the meeting died a
horrible death and I should never have
done it I should have just said here's
the story
and if you see Joseph Campbell in it
good for you but but those are those
things don't don't trick yourself just
go ahead and tell the best story that
you can
you